It’s Christmas, which means it’s the time
of year for cornering your crush under mistletoe.
Here are some things you might not know about
the plant you’re gonna smooch under.
Mistletoe might look pretty, but the plant
you’re likely to see strung as a Christmas
decoration in the United States is actually
a parasite.
It grows on a tree’s branches or trunk and
actually plants roots in its host to take
in nutrients.
There are strains of the plant that can grow
on its own, getting its own nutrients through
photosynthesis like any other plant.
But the parasitic type usually kills the tree,
but there’s a bit of a silver lining: that
dead tree makes a spot for birds to nest.
And that’s actually where mistletoe gets
its name.
Anglo-Saxons noted that the plant usually
grows where birds poop.
In Anglo-Saxon, “mistel” means “dung”
and “tan” means “twig.”
“Dung-on-a-twig” then roughly translated
to mistletoe.
And those berries?
Mistletoe berries are poisonous to cats and
other small animals and toxic to humans, though
there’s some debate over whether they’re
toxic enough to kill.
Which is strange when you think that mistletoe,
the berries and the leaves, was historically
used as a remedy.
In the 17th century, it was prescribed as
a cure for nervous disorders, epilepsy, and
spasms.
It has also been used as a digestive aid,
a heart tonic, a sedative, a treatment for
arthritis, hysteria, asthma, bed-wetting among
other things.
It was even used as a treatment for cancerous
tumours.
More recently, a study has shown that Korean
mistletoe can help fight obesity-related liver
disease.
At least, in mice.
The study was published in the Journal of
Agricultural and Food Chemistry.
According to the study, Korean mistletoe contains
a compound called “viscothionin” that
affects fat metabolism in the liver.
Obese mice who were treated with it saw their
body and liver weights drop.
So the researchers hope viscothionin could
someday be used to treat nonalcoholic fatty
liver disease in humans.
It’s precisely because of its healing properties
that mistletoe made its way into Christmas
traditions, but the kissing bit came a little
later.
It’s thought that the ritual started with
servants in England before spreading to the
middle class.
Men were allowed to steal a kiss from a woman
if she was caught standing underneath mistletoe,
and for her to refuse was bad luck.
Some traditions say that a berry had to be
taken from the plant for every kiss, effectively
capping the number of potentially unwanted
holiday smooches.
So does knowing all this give you a different
perspective on mistletoe?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.